today on the Matt Walsh show we are told
that an armed right-wing militia member
shot a quote protester who was trying to
tear down a statue but there's a lot
more a lot more to this story and were
to talk about it and I think what this
story really shows is that law and order
is officially dead in America if you
thought that already happened well maybe
it did but this is the this is the thing
that really makes it clear we'll talk
about that also five headlines including
the left's attempts to cancel a man
because they don't like the shirt that
he wore while fishing over the weekend
and also the Supreme Court has magically
discovered transgenderism in the Civil
Rights Act how do they do that we'll
discuss it that and much more all coming
up before we get to anything else though
I want to tell you about our good
friends at Rock Auto calm if you're
looking for auto parts if you got if you
got to you know take care of a problem
with your car or any vehicle that you
have no reason to go to an auto parts
store just go to rockauto.com it's so
easy to do much easier than walking into
a store a lot more convenient to the
other thing it's cheaper you know it's
it's you're gonna get the reliably low
prices you're gonna get the best prices
you can get anywhere else and they're
gonna be right there on rockauto.com
rockauto.com
what I like about it one of the many
things I like about it it's a family
business serving Auto Parts customers
online for 20 years they've been doing
this for a long time but there's still a
family business you go to rockauto.com
to shop for auto and Barty parts from
hundreds of manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low that's the one thing you
can count on is reliably low prices the
other thing you can count on is a great
selection and very easy to navigate as
well go to Rock Auto calm right now see
all the parts available for your car
truck and right Walch
in there how did you hear about us box
so that they know that we sent you
okay law and order is officially dead in
our country it's finished
it's it's done I'm afraid to say it's
one thing to have rampaging mobs in the
streets that's bad enough it's another
thing to have law enforcement and state
authorities who will not enforce the law
against that mob those are both bad
situations bad and worse situations but
it's still another thing for law
forcement and state authorities to not
only refuse to enforce the law against
these mobs these criminals but to
actively protect the criminals and
that's where we are now we've gotten all
the way to that point the law is not
just neutralized it has been twisted
perverted and is now being wielded in
favor of at the behest of according to
the demands of the mob and that's the
death of law and order it's over and
that's where we are so here's an example
the latest example and it's it's a doozy
in New Mexico a now familiar site began
to unfold yesterday a gang of criminals
a gang of vandals a gang of terrorists
decided they were going to pull down a
statue this one was of a conquistador
but they don't like you know
conquistador 500 years ago they're still
upset about it five hundred years later
these people they're still mad about
this conquistador 500 half a millennium
later they're mad now their problem with
this particular statue actually you know
what I don't care what their problem is
their problem doesn't matter I was gonna
go into the explanation of the history a
you know I don't care you shouldn't care
I don't care
mobs who tear down statues should be
defied ignored tamp down resisted
arrested I don't care why they don't
like the statue
I really don't in fact if I were in
charge I'd keep the statue up and build
another one I would say oh you don't
like the statue ok we'll build a second
one then and it's gonna be it's gonna be
twice as big just to spite you that's
what we're gonna do you know I I I would
I would this is what I would do in fact
I'm gonna run for president and my sole
campaign promise is this I'm gonna build
a I'm gonna build 300 foot statues of
Columbus in Seattle Portland San
Francisco Austin and New York that's
what I'm gonna do
and then I'll resign that's that's the
only thing I want to do as president and
that's the right way to respond I mean
I'm only half joking fact I'm not joking
at all that's how you respond to mobs as
I've argued no matter how you feel about
any of these statues and I personally
like most of them especially the ones of
Columbus I love those because he's one
of the great men of history but no
matter how you feel even if you hate the
statues you should oppose pulling them
down at the behest of a mob and you
should especially oppose the mob doing
it themselves for the sake of law and
order for the sake of good sense and
decency and civilization you should
oppose that we want to have a
conversation about a particular statue
not in a panic okay we're not all coming
together in a panic
oh no the mob doesn't like we have to do
something about that no no if you want
to have a reasonable discussion about a
statue and talk about it
we can do that you start grabbing the
ropes and the chains and and in spray
painting and defacing and crying and
screaming it's discussions over we're
not talking about it now it's the same
thing I say to my kids you know if you
have a problem with something that's
happening if you don't like something we
can talk about it but if you come here
stomping your feet and if you scream and
if you're not polite and if you don't
talk to me the way you're supposed to
we're not gonna we're not gonna have a
discussion that's what I have to say to
my kids you know my seven-year-old I
have to say this to them no matter what
you want to talk about if you're if
you're approaching me like that we're
not gonna discuss it so a lot of times I
have to say to them you know when they
when they come stomping up and screaming
I have to say no leave the room try that
again walk back to me without stomping
wipe the look off your face and and and
talk to me politely with respect and
then we'll discuss that's that's what we
need to be saying to the mob because
these are a bunch of children these are
a bunch of toddlers they have less
maturity than my seven year olds do
probably
my seven-year-olds have the advantage of
parents you know me and my wife were
parenting them a lot of these overgrown
toddlers never had that in any case the
mob showed up for this statue as per
usual law enforcement did nothing
refused to enforce the law tearing down
statues is illegal I feel like I have to
keep repeating that because you can
forget that part of it but it is
actually illegal to do this it is it is
in fact a felony to do this to destroy
property in most in most states
destroying property that's over five
hundred dollars in value is a felony
these statues are priceless these are
priceless works of art that that that
were handmade by artists years ago
centuries ago in some cases but state
and official state local officials law
and force their sitting back and letting
them do it so a group of armed citizens
being called vigilantes I believe they
would call themselves militia came to
defend the statue and this is what
happens when the government refuses to
uphold the law people take matters into
their own hands don't want that to
happen I don't want that to happen
how you stop that if you're a government
official if you're if you're in law
enforcement if you're a police chief you
do you're damned job you don't just sit
back and complain about vigilantism
don't sit there and refuse to enforce
the law and welcome chaos and anarchy
and violence in the streets and then
scold the vigilantes who step in or take
advantage or however you want to put it
enforce the law that's how you solve the
vigilante problem that's how you solve
the problem of the of the rampaging mob
you solve all those problems by
enforcing the law now so we've got the
the the criminal vandals committing a
felony we've got the armed militia
responding things of course go sideways
what do you think's gonna happen and
what we're being told by the media is
that one of the armed quote-unquote
vigilantes ended up firing into the
crowd
shooting a quote protester you know this
is how it's sort of being characterized
the Albuquerque Police Chief who again
had no interest in upholding the law and
preventing violent criminals from
defacing public property and tearing
down a priceless work of art just
because it gave them the SADS and it
made their tummy hurt he's now coming
out forcefully against the militia he
said the police chief says we are
receiving reports about vigilante groups
possibly instigating the violence if
this is true we will be holding them
accountable to the fullest extent of the
law including federal hate group
designation and prosecution here's what
the governor said let me see if I can
pull that up
Michelle Grisham says although we're
still learning more about the situation
I'm horrified and disgusted beyond words
by the reports of violence at the
protests Monday night in Albuquerque the
heavily armed individuals who flaunted
themselves at the protest calling
themselves a civil guard were there for
one reason to Menace protesters to
present an unsanctioned show of
unregulated force to Menace the people
of New Mexico with with weaponry is on
its face unacceptable that violence did
indeed occur is unspeakable unspeakable
she says now did we in fairness I
haven't checked
something tells me though that the
governor
Michelle Grisham
Hasnat there's not gonna be much of her
speaking that forcefully against the you
know left-wing mobs that have burned
down buildings and assaulted people and
throwing Molotov cocktails at police
officers as she come out and called that
violence unspeakable as she denounced
them in in terms that Strunk if she has
then great I somehow doubt that she has
most Democrat governors have not but she
also says their their actions are
unsanctioned okay what about the mob
that's they're committing the crime of
tearing down the statues that sanctioned
she's calling this a protest governor
they're committing a crime in your state
and you're calling that a protest
and if committing crimes can be a
protest and why can't a why can't a
vigilante group say that there this is a
protest on their part
now okay let's so let's this is how it's
all being characterized let's go to the
video and see the actual incident itself
here it is
[Applause]
[Music]
what you see right there to me is
clear-cut self-defense the guy I don't
know his name what blue shirt guy will
call him is retreating they attack he
shoots
self-defense he's he's a in fact he's
attacked he's hit by a someone with a
skateboard he retreats they're pursuing
him they continued to attack finally
he's tackled and then and then the shot
is fired
that would seem to me to be self-defense
right before that well here's the lead
up to what you just saw and I think I
think this this fills in all the gaps
and we have the the basically the whole
context of everything so what here's
what led up to that moment watch okay
was it necessary for him to do that no
should he have done No
she also keep in mind that this mob
again is committing a felony
this woman is initiating contact
blocking his path in order to assist in
the commission of this crime yet these
are not that there are no innocent
victims in this situation at all the mob
are all they're all criminals doing what
they have no right to do
blue shirt man has every right to walk
into that crowd they don't have a right
it's not like the mob has a right to
commit a crime unimpeded there's a back
way we're kidding it come in to crime
here no you're not allowed in
but he didn't have to pull the you know
MMA move obviously there does this
change the fact that he acted in
self-defense in the first video that we
played no I don't see that it does he's
retreating he's leaving he's standing
down they attack they attack because
they're angry at him not because he's a
continued threat he's leaving the
situation so they're mad at what he did
and they attack him
that's not legally justified that that's
not self-defense on their part and so
okay now we have an altercation that at
this point has been initiated by one of
the vandals and that's when he shoots
and that would again seem to be
self-defense to me notice something else
though
well what do they do they start calling
for the cops you hear the guy in the
video cop get the cops the cops get the
cops his license plate
you want to abolish the cops what are
you gonna do with the license plate
information if you abolish the police
officer that the cops if there's no
police officers you get someone's
license plate after they just assaulted
a woman what are you gonna do with that
information what do you think you could
do with it
no they hate the cops they want the cops
abolished yet they're calling for them
because we hit they're a bunch of tough
guys that we don't need no we don't need
no stinkin police we don't need the
palooka take care of it ourselves bunch
of tough guys
but you know the moment the the the
you-know-what hits the fan now they're
calling for the cops
but here's the real point okay
why are we even in the position of
sorting through this chaos and figuring
out who's at fault why are we in this
position in the first place why was
there even an occasion for a left-wing
criminal mob to clash with a right-wing
militia
why was there an occasion for that why
was any of this happen because the law
is not being enforced this isn't rocket
science this isn't a difficult equation
it's not hard to figure out if you if
you don't enforce the law you're gonna
end up with mobs criminals vigilantes
and militias I said that last week we
were talking about the fund the police
said you just find the police get to
guess what you're gonna have militias
and vigilante mobs guess what we just
saw
of course the defeat that the police
haven't been defunded they've just
retreated they've all but been defunded
um this is what you get this is this is
what you always get
this is always going to be the result if
the law is not going is not enforced
this is what is going to happen so
enforce the law the police should be
there
surrounding the statue arresting anyone
who tries to take it down arrest them
cuff them the minute think about
the how long is thinking about the
process of tearing down a statue this is
not something that you can do in 30
seconds
this you got to have all the the you
know you got to have all the Matias and
the chain you call the material you need
you need to get a bunch of people
together it takes time to do especially
if you're doing it shall we say
unofficially that is illegally
let's just know what around a specific
sir cuffs just letting it happen the
moment someone takes the rope and puts
it around the statue you come in and
cuff them put them in the car and send
them to jail
this is what should be happening
everywhere and no I don't I don't I
don't blame the police for this first
because they're being told to stand down
and I understand you know that the cops
are telling you to stand down you're the
this is what the brass is saying this is
what this is what people in charge is
saying if you're a police officer are
you gonna go in by yourself and try to
take on the mob no you're not going to
do that
uh you're gonna get in trouble for that
if you do it it's not gonna have any
effect you're just gonna get assaulted
by the mob so there's nothing you can do
me as an individual police officer if no
one is enforcing the law you're almost
as powerless as anyone else is around so
I understand that
but this is still a decision being made
not by individual police officers but by
people higher up
you know police chiefs and higher than
that mayors and governors decision
they're making not to enforce the law
they decide to enforce it all this goes
away okay
um
[Music]
you do that
you know if they had done that in New
Mexico that vandal never would have been
shot if that's that's a it's that simple
he might have been arrested if you had
done what you were supposed to do with
someone like that and just arrested him
to begin with for trying to tear down
statue
you would have saved them
now from what I understand he's and he's
not he fortunately didn't die but you
would have saved him from being in
critical condition in the hospital
by the way the Vandal last week that I
don't know if you saw that video I don't
remember if we played it on the show or
not they're tearing down a statue
somewhere the statue falls right on top
of one of these guys splits his head
open
you enforce the law there and that guy
never never suffers what I'm sure was
brain damage that doesn't happen
that's the other thing that we miss in
is tearing down a statue is it's that's
dangerous this is a large very heavy
object that you're tearing down
mob of people all surrounding it it's
dangerous in and of itself that should
be reason enough to enforce the law is
that it's dangerous to do
there's a reason why you wouldn't send a
mob of 50 people out to just randomly
chop down a tree that's a that's a
dangerous procedure and you need to be
very careful in how you do it or
someone's going to get hurt or killed
it's dangerous in itself and then it's
dangerous when you when you mix in other
groups of people that are trying to stop
it from happening
so that's reason enough
but this is this is just our the people
in charge our elected leaders so-called
leaders
leaders in name only this is a decision
that they've made
not going to enforce the law
going to protect the lawbreakers
vied them with a forum I'm gonna clear
the path give them space to destroy is
what the mayor of Baltimore said years
ago
that was a
Baltimore riots few years ago after the
Freddie gray case and the mayor
Baltimore said we have to give the
rioters space to destroy that was an
outrageous and terrifying thing to hear
one mayor say about what was happening
in Baltimore this is now what is
happening across the country governor's
across the country mayor's across the
country are saying this is space to
destroy the entire country apparently is
space for the mob to destroy
it's only going to get worse I'm afraid
to say
let's go to let's go to news headlines
number one a lot of news we'll start
with this of course a profoundly
significant decision from the Supreme
Court yesterday and a profoundly
terrible one my friend Josh hammer calls
this the roe v-- wade of religious
liberty which which seems to be a pretty
good way of putting it a six justice
majority led by neil Gorsuch Trump's
pick one of the reasons we were told we
had to elect Trump instead of one of the
other Republicans is that Trump will
give us great Supreme Court picks you
know he's gonna be the guy who gives us
the really good ones but not so much as
it turns out
Trump Supreme Court picks have been a
little bit like his wall it was supposed
to be big and beautiful across two
thousand miles and you know ends up
being a little bit of fencing here and
there not nearly as impressive as he
promised to put it mildly
anyway Gorsuch in the liberal justices
to include john roberts found that title
seven of the Civil Rights Act of 1964
which is supposed to protect against
sex-based discrimination in employment
also applies to gender identity and
sexual orientation now there are so many
problems here that it's hard to count
and I would recommend reading Josh's
piece of the New York Post you could
read Ryan T Anderson the daily signal
he's always got great stuff on this or
listen to been on this I mean as I'm
sure you already have they're going to
give you a more comprehensive analysis
than what you'll hear from me because
they're experts in the legal issues that
at play here
to my mind just briefly a few things
jump out at me first being that the
Supreme Court's job is to tell us what
the law says that's their job to settle
disputes about what the law says no
reasonable person actually thinks that
title seven really means to protect
gender identity whatever that even means
because none of the people responsible
for title seven for that statute had any
concept of our modern notion of gender
identity that wasn't a thing they didn't
they didn't no one talked about that
they most certainly did not mean to
include that in fact people with a
modern notion of gender identity in
modern times don't have any actual
notion of what it really is because it's
an
generic concept but the point is that
that title seven everyone knows doesn't
actually protect gender identity doesn't
doesn't really do that liberals think
that it should which okay is a different
argument the Supreme Court is not
supposed to be changing laws to make
them into what they should be
that's the legislators job that's why we
that's why we elect lawmakers to do that
the decision and that's what this
decision was it was it was legislation
it wasn't saying this is what the law
says it was saying this is what the law
should say and so now we're gonna
pretend that it does say that also the
implications here are enormous and
troubling of course to turn gender
identity into a protected class opens
Pandora's Box essentially what the
justices have done here is codify into
law the idea that biological males are
female if they say they are a biological
man man male can be protected on the
under the same statute that protects
women from discrimination if he says
that he's a woman which means that we
are now legally recognizing that a man
who says he's a woman even though isn't
actually magically therefore turns into
one and now now that they're in a
protected class does that mean that
religious employers religious schools
churches are not allowed to make hiring
decisions according to their religion
does it mean that men now have a
god-given human right to enter into
women's locker rooms and bathrooms and
sports teams those issues aren't
directly mentioned in this decision but
that obviously is the groundwork that
has been laid and all of that is coming
next so that's what we have to look
forward to speaking of the rule of law
being dead number two the Boy Scouts of
America have come out and of course bend
the knee in Ballad before BLM and the
radical left no surprise their BSA has
been bowing to the radical left for
years now that's why the organization is
dying and deserves to die it just serves
no I mean there's no reason to put your
kids in the Boy Scouts now I have I
don't know what I don't know what you
would be thinking if you if you did
they're just the Boy Scouts don't they
basically don't exist they exist in name
only now but there's no reason if you're
looking for whatever you're turning to
the Boy Scouts for there are better
organizations and the Boy Scouts now but
also the Boy Scouts they came up with a
merit badge this is the latest in their
effort to you know show off how woke and
enlightened they are there's a new merit
badge it's the inclusion and diversity
badge that will be required of any Scout
who wants to become an Eagle Scout right
diversity and inclusion
that's the badge which is an important
life skill isn't it
diversity inclusion I mean that's you
know if you're if you're out in the
woods trying to survive I can just
imagine you know imagine someone someone
someone coming out of the wilderness
after spending two months in there
and and you asked them you say you know
how did you do it how did you survive
and they say well I recalled my training
as a scout
let me thank God I'm an Eagle Scout I
knew how to build a fire I knew how to
hunt
know how to fish I knew how to build a
shelter but most importantly I'm very
skilled in the area of diversity and
inclusion
I was just including stuff everywhere
that was the main thing that's how I
survived by including so much
stuff was included I was including left
and right that's what saved me number
three the latest victim of canceled
calls culture is Oklahoma State football
coach Mike Gundy Gundy apparently went
on a fishing trip recently wearing an OE
n shirt Oh a n is one American news
network a conservative news organization
that has really been the target of the
left's wrath in particular recently
because Trump has has mentioned them a
few times and he went wearing he's
wearing a shirt Oh an shirt that's all
the shirt just says OAM that's all it
says and now the left has gone to work
canceling him for a shirt that he wore
while fishing some brave journalists
found a picture on Facebook and posted
that Twitter got the mob worked up then
some players said they they're gonna
refuse to play for Gundy because because
of the shirt and on and on and on and
that's how it goes and Gundy has already
come out and I mean all but apologized
for the shirt and said that he's gonna
work hard on you know bridging the gap
and blah blah blah blah blah that that
whole thing so we know how this goes but
they're at the point now or they want to
control the shirt you wear when you go
fishing they think that's their business
they're gonna they basically what I
guess the idea is they should be able to
dress you in the morning everything you
do is their business and if you do
anything in any context or say anything
in any context past present or future
and they don't like it they should be
able to destroy your life
number four Thomas Jefferson statue has
been torn down by vandals in Portland I
you know this should not surprise us
some of us have been warning about this
for years
in fact I back when I when I work for
the blaze I don't know four years ago or
more I wrote an article saying they're
gonna come for the you know went win
that when that round of Confederate
statues were being torn down back you
know four or five years ago I wrote an
article I wasn't the only one but making
the argument that this this is
groundwork that's being laid and they're
coming for the Confederate statues next
it's gonna be the founders and if you
don't want the founders to be torn down
to you if you don't want Columbus to be
torn down if you don't want this to
continue
then you need to resist the mob even
here when it comes to Confederate
statues because as I keep saying no
matter how you feel about those statues
if you start appeasing the mob and
letting them tear it down and supporting
them in doing it and making arguments in
their favor you have you have you have
opened the floodgates and there's not
gonna be any closing it especially when
you listen to the reason why they want
these statues torn down one of the big
things you hear by the Confederate
statues is well we got to turn it tear
it down because these are slave owners
who are racist well okay that there are
it's a lot more than Confederates who
fall into that category
a lot of slave owners existed in the
world prior to you know the 19th century
19th century and earlier a lot of slave
owners all across the world not just
white people 19th century and earlier
everybody was racist by modern standards
so if we're saying you could tear
statues down for that reason then
they're all coming down Washington and
Jefferson forget about there they're
finished they were racist men who owned
slaves no doubt about that can't can't
deny it but as always the commune oaken
Servat oftheir just historically
especially in recent times conservatives
are just so obtuse and so slow to pick
up on what's happening around them this
has been the great frustration for me
for years is how slow conservatives
you've got the left focusing intensely
on some area of the culture war while
conservatives say gots a sideshow
doesn't matter yeah they're just just
let them get it out of their system
it'll it'll end there I'm sure do you
understand now how this works it
never ends it never ends if you if you
agree with them on this area here if you
try to appease them here it's it's not
gonna end okay something a little
positive something to brighten your day
I think we'll end with number five take
a look at this video you want to see is
the party of the black black the
Republican Party is the only party that
the black people actually assisted in
finding but all of that history has been
thrown away people say oh there was this
big switch there was never a big switch
the Union the Union wider because we had
grown in the industrial area era so we
were able to get trains and get supplies
back to our soldiers while the
confederate was still riding horses then
when I able to get supplies right so
what happened was when slavery was
abolished in the south if people who
were south como no longer make their
money from slaves they had to move to
the north to work in the industry to
produce and so the people in the norm
that already had established themselves
an industry
and I don't think I need to add anything
to that I think it's just great stuff
there's there's a woman who knows what
she's talking about where to get to your
daily cancellation in just a second
before we do you know so much going on
the news we just ran through a lot of it
I know it's kind of overwhelming and you
want to be able to sort through what
you're hearing that's why you need to
get a reader's pass today from daily
wire.com you'll get access to exclusive
op-eds from us your podcasts as well as
guest writers and in-depth analysis from
our daily wire reporters on top of our
regular breaking news you get all of
that this Membership tier is already a
bargain at 3 bucks a month but if you
join today and get your first month for
99 cents you also get access to our
mobile app and receive push
notifications for breaking news and
special content as well as you join the
community of daily wire members who are
actively commenting and discussing our
content with each other that's mobile ad
free access to all of our daily wire
news exclusive op-eds and more onto our
mobile app all for the low price of just
$1 best of all your dollars are getting
you the news you need without the left
to spin so head over to daily wire comm
slash subscribe and join today for our
daily cancellation today I'm going to
cancel anyone who tries to use Jesus to
justify rioting and mob rule I've seen a
lot of this kind of thing in recent
weeks
for example there's this tweet which
went massively viral is like 150,000
plus retweets it says I swear to god
Christians forget that Jesus was
publicly executed by the government for
being a threat to their
power and causing political unrest and
more recently there's this the Reverend
Lenny Duncan says Jesus was a man of
color murdered by law enforcement and
state sanctioned violence for
insurrection against the Roman Empire
and then if you go to this article from
NPR with with Lenny Duncan you see him
there with the black lives matter robe
on and and there's an interview with him
and he says he has a lot to say
among them he compares Trayvon Martin to
Jesus okay so just to give you an idea
of where this guy is coming from the
attempt to make Jesus into a leader of
the mob the leader of a violent
insurrectionist movement much like an
Tifa and to say that he was killed by a
government fearful of his threat to
their power I mean that's the kind of
take on the passion story that you might
have if you've never read the passion
story but here's my strategy okay it's
pretty radical pretty wild I admit but
before I form an opinion on a thing
especially a biblical thing I like to
read the thing that that's just that's
how I approach it okay it my personal
preference we all have our own way of
going about it but I figure if I'm going
to have something to say about this
maybe I should know what it is I don't
know just an idea and when I do that I
discover that know Jesus was not killed
because he was an insurrectionist who
threatened Rome's power that's a
convenient way of looking at it if
you're a leftist in modern America
that's not actually what happened rome
couldn't care less about jesus they had
there's a reason why contemporary Roman
historians and and and other
contemporaries in the Roman Roman
government who were around at the time
of Jesus none of them mention him in
their record books he - then he was just
an itinerant preacher you know a Jewish
preacher going around and you know
preaching his
religion I didn't care about that in
fact the Roman authorities cleared Jesus
of the insurrection charge it's a pretty
crucial part of the passion narrative we
know he's eat the high priest bring
Jesus to Pilate and Pilate interrogate
him and says I don't see any problem
with the guy it's I just don't see it
he's he's I'm paraphrasing but he says
that you know he the guy he appears to
be innocent to me ultimately Pilate
orders Jesus's execution why does he do
that and here's the crucial point why is
it why does Pilate order the execution
of Jesus it's not because Pilate as the
governing authority is afraid of Jesus
or thinks he's an insurrectionist or as
a threat to their power no it's because
the mob demanded the mob shouted crucify
him Pilate ordered the execution he did
something he knew was wrong
ignoring in fact ignoring Roman law
because the mob demanded it so if
there's any lesson here you know aside
from the theological lessons that can be
applied to this current situation in
America it's about mob rule it's about
it's about this is why you don't cave to
the mob this is why governing
authorities need to uphold the rule of
law the execution of Jesus was not done
in an attempt to uphold the rule of law
it was really done in defiance of the
rule of law it was done because the rule
of the mob had supplanted the rule of
law hey this is what happens when a
governing authority caves to the mob and
gives a violent mob whatever they want
you end up executing the Messiah okay
that's the real lesson but what you find
from leftist activists is that they can
take and this is just one example but
they can take a story out of the Bible
that conduct completely opposes their
worldview and everything they're doing
and they can twist it in support of them
I think they can they can make it say
the the exact opposite of what it
actually says and as I said this is just
one example but everyone doing that is
is therefore cancelled and maybe we
should all go and you know it's it's a
good practice in general to actually
read the Bible so maybe go actually read
the passion story you might you might
you might find some stuff in there that
surprises you if you've never actually
read it but but you've gone around
giving your opinion on it regardless all
right we'll leave it there thanks for
watching everybody have a great day
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 Gorsuch betrays conservatives
transgenderism is now a protected class
and Chas changes its name to chop it's
very fitting very french revolution
check it all that on the Michael Nolt
show
[Music]